there are so many atrocities coming out
of this white house every day
it's easy to get distracted but i want
to bring us back to focus on something
we can't afford to forget
and that is healthcare jimmy kimmel
shares never-before-seen glimpses at his
son's health battle
and now he's encouraging fans to vote in
the upcoming presidential election
with their heart my wife molly made a
video
that deals with our experience when it
comes to pre-existing conditions
and we'd like you to watch this and pass
it around to anyone who may have
forgotten what this election
is really about on jimmy kimmel live
thursday
the late night host set up a video
montage that showed some of the hospital
visits and surgeries he and his wife
molly mcnearney
experienced with their then newborn son
william john
who is now three years old william who
they call billy
had to undergo three heart surgeries one
when he was just three days old
after he was born with a heart condition
by
sharing the video jimmy and molly who
also share a six-year-old daughter jane
wanted to put health care at the
forefront of voters minds heading into
the presidential election on november
3rd
the vast majority of this country agrees
that health insurance should cover
americans with pre-existing conditions
but the republican party
and that includes the president and
members of congress the only plan they
have
is to do away with protections for
pre-existing conditions if they're
allowed to do that
millions of people are going to suffer
during the segment we see photos and
clips of billy just after his birth
his stint in the nicu and at his many
hospital visits
the video points out billy's three heart
surgeries and reveals he's had over
60 doctor appointments in his short life
and while addressing president donald
trump's attacks on the affordable care
act
and the potential effect it may have on
families with a loved one who has a
pre-existing condition
molly writes moms don't forget please
vote
and at the end of the video molly adds
quote we are raising him to fight for
less fortunate kids
americans take care of one another vote
with your heart
six days after open heart surgery we got
to bring him home which is amazing
jimmy who also has two older children
kevin and katie from
a previous relationship first opened up
about his son's condition
in may 2017 with an emotional monologue
on his show they did an echocardiogram
which is a sonogram of the heart and
found that billy was born
with um a heart disease
this is what he looked like on monday
but this is what he looked like um
yesterday
poor kid not only to get a bad heart he
got my face
when e.t caught up with jimmy as he
prepped to host the oscars in 2018
he opened up about how his experience
with billy's health journey changed his
perspective
it makes me more thankful in general for
sure
to be honest it minimizes the importance
of something
like this which last year seemed to me
to be the most important thing in the
world and then you get this
reminder that this is even close to the
most important thing in the world
and you're reminded of that every day
when you go home but so
in a way it yes it definitely has made
me appreciate my life
more it also puts things in perspective